so let's talk about the best food to
pevent pops okay what is a polyp well
it's an abnormal tissue and I'm going to
teach you a new word pedunculated
okay pedunculated means that it has a
little bit of a stem growing off of
something like in your colon you have
these little stems or stalks that can
grow that's what a polyp is go ahead and
say it with me a pedunculated so now
you can tell your friends and family
that a polyp is a pedunculated tissue in
your colon certain polyps have a higher
risk of colon cancer hands down the best
type of food to help prevent the growth
of polyps would be sauerkraut or pickled
vegetables why because they contain
lactic acid bacteria and lactobacillus
is one type of lactic acid bacteria it's
a specific bacteria that is l plus okay
so sauerkraut has this version and these
properties it inhibits pathogens it's an
antioxidant it's an anti-inflammatory
because when you have inflammation your
colon that by itself can stimulate tumor
growth also this bacteria helps to tight
junctions in your colon so it can
prevent leaky gut also this friendly
bacteria binds to carcinogens which are
things that cause cancer it will also
decrease mutations and decrease pre
cancer growth the benefits of sauerkraut
or pickled vegetables is that you not
only have the probiotic you have the
prebiotic the fiber which then feeds the
microbe it makes short chain fatty acids
one being butyrate which then can reduce
the stimulation of tumors polyps and
decrease inflammation
now you don't need a tremendous amount
but through the week I would definitely
include either sauerkraut or pickled
vegetables and your diet thanks for
watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering on keto absolutely not Karen and
it's an immune system builder absolutely
you have to check this out I think you
should hurry up watch the recipe and
make it yourself it's just so easy to be
keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy making it as much as we
are enjoying eating it